okay let's continue our story on the
history of server-side computing at this
time we enter the race for scalability
because once the computer rack was
created we could start to stack servers
on top of each other to save space and
this was of course great but now another
problem surfaced because even though
these servers were great from a stacking
perspective it was still the case that
one application could only run on one
server and this became a big problem
because as the internet grew these
applications got more and more popular
and more and more popular and more and
more popular and since there is a limit
to the performance of one server this
architecture was not sustainable and had
to be abandoned the one application one
server strategy was a dead-end street
and a radically new solution was
required